got approached by a company once to make
a natsuki doll
and you'd squeeze it and be like go [ __ ]
yourself
[Laughter]
why did you not say yesterday sounds
like a genius idea i don't know i
don't know i didn't want to exploit
natsuki i think he wanted that
i think natalie i asked him yeah yeah so
i might still do it i might still do it
and also now you've said it now
you're never gonna hear the enemy you
don't want the nasty delty ladies and
gentlemen they they
are you kidding me i wanna i wanna know
i wanna ask you i want one as well
yeah go [ __ ] yourself it needs to be
like you squeeze it and it's like yeah
it's like a random
quotes right 20 quotes that's easy why
would you not do that it's such low
hanging fruit they wanted to take over
all my merchandise and i said no
oh okay so i thought well i'll steal
that idea
i'm sure you could find a manufacturer i
can do that for you somebody help me
email me so you're sorry you we got an
attention because you're talking about
filming in uh
i said it's about merchandise
yeah yeah so yeah so i mean there's
still places that i've been to that are
very easy picking so that's it yeah i
feel like japan is just
like a [ __ ] gold mine of weird and
wonderful places
i just like to find the kind of unique
stuff yeah yeah i went to a place with
just
replica easter island heads in hokkaido
like
20 easter island yeah yeah it's a
cemetery no i never thought
how can we respect the dead easter
island heads
and it kind of it's pretty cool and it's
like to scale it look normal they had a
massive face mask on it
so your this video is just like about
the area but
yeah pretty much just is it harder to do
that when there's so many interesting
things in a place
where you're like [ __ ] that seems like a
video id you would have done like we
tried
so i did with ryotaro we tried to find
retro places kind of unique
places that are kind of old showa era
places
yeah did you wear a kimono you bet i
didn't
i like you didn't you know a photo of
you in front of soju with the kimono
yeah so
when we went to do the the kawari
smashing which is right next
to sakta kaho was like let's just wear
kimonos
it didn't look worryingly good on me
thanks man in a way that i can't do
because it just makes me look around
you'd look like a land baron it would
shoot you
i would oh yeah my property is just over
here
like kimonos looks so bad on me every
time i do a video oh people sometimes
will get annoyed about it as well which
is really [ __ ] stupid i think
oh well because it's like appropriation
or whatever right yeah
you know i didn't look at that and think
cultural appropriation
how dare you i [ __ ] splashed my eye
with the water
i thought that was
[Music]
yeah of course i mean you know it's one
of those things where i i feel like if
you're not being a [ __ ] and not
running around or spilling [ __ ] on it
yeah yeah yeah
i think the only time i was in the sort
of cultural appropriation camp on that
front was when um
kim kardashian kimono underwater and
like you know you could
you could see a future 10 years down the
line had she followed through where like
kids might have been like oh yeah the
kimonos
kim kardashian's brand yeah yeah
historical context or cultural context
i agree with that i'd consider cultural
appropriation yeah absolutely yeah and
just full-blown country
yeah and uh yeah i was i was kind of
like loads of japanese women like don't
take up don't take that name and then
ruin it yeah and i was like yeah
yeah absolutely i often find that
especially in asian countries
people like people here seem to like are
happy to have you
kind of adopt their culture yeah yeah
yeah i would love it i mean
that's that's how like the whole nihongo
jozu thing really like happened right
because you speak one word of japanese
and everyone's just like
nihongo jozu well done you've been part
of our culture finally
it's funny right because it's to us now
we here like to explain
whenever you speak like any japanese
like to like
you could be ordering food or something
right and a japanese person will say
nihongo josu even if you just [ __ ]
said like you're saying if you said
arigato or something in the worst
japanese accent they would say like
oh nihongo jozu but like i i feel like
they do that because they're just like
so happy that a foreigner took the time
to like
learn that like why would they learn our
language yeah yeah and i feel i feel
like it's just
it's it's more towards like asian
culture in general